[Música]
ya son cinco años desde que se cometió
el genocidio contra la minoría musulmana
rohingya de mianmar declarado como tal
por la organización de naciones unidas
el 25 de agosto del año 2017 el ejército
y la policía de birmania myanmar de
mayoría budista inicio de esta operación
catalogada como limpieza étnica contra
esta población en el estado de rakhine
fronterizo con bangladesh estos hechos
incluyeron masacres violaciones y quema
de viviendas de los rohingyas el saldo
al menos un millón de desplazados que
huyeron al vecino bangladesh y 25 mil
asesinados recientemente la corte
internacional de justicia lleva una
investigación sobre estos hechos y
prepara el escenario para audiencias que
dejen en evidencia estas atrocidades una
es la minoría musulmana saludamos
entonces a nuestro primer invitado el
día nos acompaña nuestro estudio él es
alejandro goic consultor en geopolítica
y especialista en relaciones
hemisféricas de asia alejandro gracias
por estar con nosotros esta mañana la
invitación alejandro le quiero preguntar
por qué entonces inició este genocidio
por parte de los militares hasta hacia
esta minoría musulmana desde siempre
existía una asistencia muy grande sobre
el pueblo rojilla que realmente nunca
tiene un estatus de ser ciudadanos eso
por un lado digamos existe un momento
histórico que es desde el siglo 19
cuando vemos que ellos pelearon a favor
de los británicos posteriormente
estuvieron otra vez a favor de los
británicos y cuando se da la
independencia de mianmar en 1948 aún
sang papa de esta mujer tasa
introvertida y condenada a 11 años que
ya no sé hablar de ella precisamente
entonces en este contexto siguió
viéndose como ella no apoyó precisamente
a ellos en su liberación y porque el año
2017 porque en el 2017 se forma un
movimiento que se llama liberación por
el pueblo rojilla en este contexto y
obviamente la respuesta de los militares
es desproporcionada dando las
consecuencias de una masacre de un lado
y también un refugiados tan grandes para
mí amar entre otros países entre digamos
bangladesh y la india también ahora tras
cinco años desde el inicio
acometida digamos a ellos denuncia que
no están dadas las condiciones para su
regreso muchísimos de ellos por supuesto
quieren regresar a su país pero porque
es algo también muy importante porque no
son tratadas como océanos por lo que nos
estaba explicando en ese momento digamos
que ellos nunca van a tener entonces
gustativa ciudadanos dentro de su propio
país eso es lo más triste claro viene
una venganza histórica de un lado y de
otro lado dicen como hay una junta
militar que desde siempre se ha sentido
desconectada y recordemos mí al mar es
un país budista donde la religión pesa
mucho y esto hace que no sean
reconocidos por ende se fueron a
bangladesh y ahora también están en la
india pero en la india también sucede
con ellos una situación compleja la
mayoría de la población de la index
hinduista y el gobierno está haciendo
también una política de cacería contra
los rohingya y los está aislando en dos
estados que también donde no se ve una
política de mejoramiento de sus
condiciones de vida -alejandro idioma
que más allá de todo esto se da esta
segregación esta persecución por razones
religiosas más que todo uno razones
religiosas pero también hay que recordar
que en el estado de rap y en al canto
existen unas reservas muy importantes de
gas y eso precisamente también hace que
se busque la desaparición de la minoría
rojin ya para que se pueda dar una
política más grande hacia varios socios
que tienen y amar sobre este importante
gasoducto como como empeora la situación
para los rohingyas con una junta militar
en el poder tras el golpe de estado de
febrero hay que recordar algo si bien
lanzan such y premio nobel de la paz una
mujer bastante controvertida donde más
de 13 noveles de la paz denunciaron que
ella realmente nunca ha apoyado al
pueblo rojilla en su institución como
ciudadanos obviamente lo que hizo por
supuesto fue acelerar este tema de no
ser reconocidos otro también dar un
golpe militar en lo que viene con todo
el tema base de encontrarse con falta de
libertades y que no tienen por supuesto
las garantías para volver a su país
aunque por supuesto la junta militar lo
que dice ellos son de origen de
bangladesh y nunca tienen por qué tener
ese estatus de ciudadanos es el
escenario más triste para esta comunidad
ahora sí hablemos del papel de hans
anschütz y por qué pues llama la
atención digamos que esto ocurrió en
2017 cuando ella estaba liderando el
país realmente no hizo nada aún son
succi para proteger a esta minoría
musulmana rohingya los militares
evidentemente fueron los primeros que
impulsaron toda esta persecución todo
este genocidio digamos que los militares
entonces siempre han dirigido mianmar y
la figura de sanssouci era algo más como
política pero sin acción total sobre el
territorio si es que el rol de ella es
muy complejo porque nunca tuvo poder de
decisión pese a vender de ser su padre
uno de los hombres fundadores de van de
mianmar en este concepto y
adicionalmente a esto ella estuvo
siempre maniatada y hay que recordar con
el referendo del año 2008 en este
momento se vio que la junta militar ganó
muchísimo más poder y protagonismo y
ahora condenada más de 11 años de
prisión es muy difícil ya que una mujer
de 76 años puedan volver a ver la luz en
temas políticos
también alejando la corte internacional
de justicia está ya investigando estos
crímenes cometidos contra la población
pero teniendo en cuenta este escenario
teniendo en cuenta que los militares
ahorita están en el poder de miramar
controlando todo el territorio que tan
real es que los responsables de esta
está de este genocidio pues váyanse a
ser juzgados por una corte internacional
sí esto lleva años en la decisión por un
lado y recordar que el país que empezó
con esto cambia un país africano hoy por
hoy por supuesto apoyado por entre otros
países bajos noruega entre otros
nórdicos es muy difícil porque además
los procesos duran muchos años y
mientras tanto la situación de los
rohingyas se sigue escalando para el
fondo es lo más complejo que vemos en
este momento entonces no es una real
justicia es más bien un suceso simbólico
para visibilizar los pero la ayuda
económica no llega a las comunidades
porque no llega sello económica a las
comunidades también es recordemos que
michelle bachelet
es el líder de los derechos humanos de
la onu estuvo en bangladesh y también
pues se dijo en sus declaraciones que
estaba muy preocupada por la situación
de estos indios en los campamentos cuál
es la situación real de esta población y
por qué digamos que no son asentados en
unas condiciones básicas para tener una
unas condiciones de vida mínimas no
accesos acceso a servicios básicos por
ejemplo también qué pasa con las
regencias que fueron enviados a ir a una
isla totalmente remota que ha pasado con
estas personas así es es muy triste
porque dice bangladesh yo apoyo a los
rohingyas pero realmente lo que está
haciendo es un proceso de alienación de
ellos guardarlos en esa isla vas a echar
desde diciembre del 2020 exc una isla
que apareció hace 20 años que no tiene
por supuesto las medidas pasan tifones
es terrible y por otro lado también
organizaciones internacionales como save
the children acnur entre otras tratan de
hacer su mayor esfuerzo pero en un mundo
como sabemos y sobre todo en este 2022
que ocurren tantas situaciones que hay
tantos desplazados en el planeta lo que
se está viendo es una falta de fondos y
que al ser una minoría tan pero por
supuesto representativa musulmana no no
llegan los recursos para que estas
comunidades sean realmente impactadas de
forma favorable el problema cuál es los
niños entonces no se está dando una
posibilidad de que ellos estudien además
está dando también un proceso de
aculturación donde no se les enseña a
ellos en su idioma claro ya para
finalizar rápidamente alejandro como el
futuro de los rohingyas se va a quedar
en estas condiciones
por el resto de sus generaciones es muy
triste no los vemos hacinados en campos
de refugiados que es lo más complejo si
unas bandas criminales también que están
vendiendo drogas en desde cuando se
exactamente y por otro lado también una
falta de bases de cultura que es lo que
nos estamos encontrando se por ende lo
que estamos viendo es una desaparición
paulatina de los rohingyas que es lo más
grave y el mundo está haciendo poco
sobre esta situación